Oh Lord their cipher graph so many penis
jokes I'm not kidding my name is
Catherine burns and I am a choreographer
it's hard to answer like what was the
moment when people started realizing
what I did I don't know it just became
people telling me you had to go to
person for comedy choreography I was
like oh really cool it it comedy bang
bang what hot American summer is
Children's Hospital another period I've
heard of Carly Rae Jepsen Pharrell I'm a
happy video there's my crazy
ex-girlfriend workaholics drunk history
that we got over a hundred and fifty
episodes of TV but I'll keep to naming
key and Peele two Broke Girls when
people hear that I was in a Weird Al
video and that I choreographed it like
done like dead as I think a lot of
choreographers say I was born dancing
and moving and wiggling and things but
my first actual class was I was five
years old with ballet and then in high
school I did our drill team which really
informs a lot of my work in the fence
because it's all about clean lines and
like strong visuals and Texas drill team
is no joke the biggest soul-crushing
thing was I was ever Rockettes at
audition year after year I was so
heartbroken and I was an alternate but
never hired finally after like seven
years I was like time to hang up this
dream but I wouldn't be where I am now
had I been a Rockette life of a dancer
[Music]
I've always been a fan of musical comedy
my dad and I would watch a lot of
slapstick movies with your bad therapist
so maybe you're the one like that has a
blanket and a pillow I started working
on shows at UCB kind of right when it
started because it was pretty new to the
LA scene it could be a lot of like
fingers in his face and pointing and I
was pretty hungry and available let's
head back count it because I think
there's no like four beats right you see
be so great for being a breeding ground
of some of the best comedic minds so by
default of taking improv and doing
sketches and classes here the people I
was doing a sketch with ended up going
on to be a writer on a TV show who
pitched me to choreograph and so luckily
that one thing led to another thing
which gave me to a place where I could
quit my side job which was honestly
that's like the biggest goal in LA like
just being able to quit your side jobs
and do what you love to do for a living
is the real gay
[Music]
[Music]
what I get to do is I get to like
authentically recreate /live +
reinterpret any genre any style but yet
it's up to me to also heighten the joke
far as a comedy choreography is
concerned they wear droopy used to be
comedic vaudeville was comedic and a lot
of times like the way I approach
choreography for comedy is like if this
wasn't funny it would be cool you don't
mean physics girlfriend isn't a thing
that people know me for we did 157 music
videos I think one of the most special
numbers which sums up crazy
ex-girlfriend is antidepressants or so
not a big deal and the song lyrically
totally embodies why you would do a
musical you're hopped up on medication
you're normally depressed but here take
these pills and you'll be hyper and
that's the meals like and then you do a
crazy fast top rate because you're all
medicated and you're happy the key and
Peele was really important for me one of
the first sketches was he gonna Dourdan
being like a boyband duo so that was a
fun one and then like aerobics meltdown
which ended up being this awesome viral
video I also realized I don't like
talking about myself that much that's
what's okay good I feel like I have an
episode of drunk history where I'm like
and then they dance cut to them cut to
the dancing duh-duh-duh
tap tap tap tap grande jeté bleep turn
follow the floor
[Music]
the most challenging thing about stage
versus TV is the choreography might have
worked great for stage but like if
camera isn't in a wide then it's just
not gonna read the dancers should still
down to the top of error ability not to
dance bad because you have an
eight-count to impress it just happens
to be a song about penises or whatever
it may be you know I mean I always knew
that I had a little bit more energy and
spunk than your average dancer you don't
purposely try to be funny but people are
laughing which can give you a bit of
confidence I guess it's interesting as
we get older that we kind of lose a
sense of play so I haven't aged much
because my industry lets me play people
I get to create these things that live
on forever so when I die my in memoriam
is gonna be so weird and fun they better
make some like montage thing of all my
silly crazy picture
you
[Music]